en este vídeo vamos a hablar de una de
las ideas más importantes en matemáticas
y es saber si el orden importa cuando
multiplicas dos números así que por
ejemplo es lo mismo 3 por 4 que 4 por 3
son estas dos expresiones iguales y sin
importar si estas dos expresiones son
iguales será siempre el caso de que si
tengo un número por otro y cambio el
orden
entonces voy a obtener un resultado
equivalente bueno pausa el vídeo y
piensa un poco en ello intenta pensarlo
un poco antes de que lo pensemos juntos
también pensemos un poco en este ejemplo
en particular y vamos a necesitar un
poco de ayuda de algunos gatos enojados
aquí puedes ver a nuestros gatos
enojados
[Música]
están enojados podemos verlo tenemos
tres grupos de cuatro observar este es
uno de los grupos de cuatro gatos
enojados aquí tenemos dos grupos de
cuatro gatos enojados y por último aquí
tenemos tres grupos de cuatro gatos
enojados esto nos sirve si vemos el
primer número de aquí como grupos del
segundo número pero también podemos
verlo como cuatro grupos de tres como es
eso posible
bueno aquí hay un grupo de tres gatos
enojados podemos tener dos grupos de
tres gatos enojados aquí otro grupo más
de tres gatos enojados y bueno por acá
podemos tener cuatro grupos de tres
gatos enojados así que con base en esto
si pensamos en el primer número como
grupos del segundo entonces parece que
el orden no importa otra forma de verlo
es que aquí tenemos cuatro filas
tres gatos enojados tenemos una dos tres
cuatro filas de uno dos tres gatos
enojados para saber el número total de
gatos enojados que tienes entonces
multiplicamos cuatro por tres y ya está
sin embargo podemos ver el mismo grupo
de gatos enojados de una perspectiva
ligeramente distinta aquí tengo a mis
gatos enojados y ahora déjame
derrotarlos tal vez arriesgándome que se
enojen un poco más y ahora podemos ver
esto como tres filas de cuatro gatos
cada fila así que déjame ponerlo por acá
una dos tres filas de uno dos tres
cuatro gatos quitar esto para que no sea
confuso y claro estamos trabajando con
el mismo número de gatos y estoy
trabajando con tres y cuatro pero como
puedes ver el orden no importa cuando
estás multiplicando dos números
es más podemos ver esto mismo en una
recta numérica
así que bajaré la pantalla pero dejaré
algunos gatos enojados observándonos y
observa si pensamos en tres por cuatro
podemos verlo como cuatro veces tres es
decir tengo 3 6 9 12
o lo podemos ver como 3 veces 4 tengo 4
8 12 ya nos hemos enfocado bastante en
13 4 pero podemos trabajar con cualquier
par de números que estamos intentando
multiplicar no sé se me ocurre que ahora
veamos 6 por 4 6 por 4 es lo mismo que 4
por 6 bueno primero pensemos en 6 veces
4 4 8 12 16 20 y por último 24 o podemos
verlo como 4 veces 6
una vez 6 12 18 24 la conclusión más
importante es que no importa el orden
cuando estás multiplicando números como
estos a veces se refieren a esto como la
propiedad conmutativa que es una palabra
elegante pero realmente lo que nos dice
es que es lo mismo si hacemos 6 por 4
que 4 por 6
la propiedad conmutativa de la
multiplicación nos dice oye estas dos
expresiones van a ser equivalentes
si están enojados porque los rotamos